cyberpunk developer has opened up about
more changes coming to the game and
elden ring fans have discovered a
missing feature
let's start with cyberpunk reddit user
camille cesaro posted a twitter clip
from cyberpunk 2077 quest director paul
sasco in which the developer provided a
brief behind-the-scenes view of cd
projekt red's priorities sasko said
quote i can assure you that we are
working on an expansion we're working on
stuff you guys besides that that didn't
change we are still improving the game
because we are all aware there is work
to be done this is in line with cd
projekt red's message from a year ago
about how abandoning cyberpunk 2077
isn't an option sasko continued by
saying that's as much as i can tell you
we're working on stuff for you like i'm
literally daily reviewing quests or
talking to people about stuff so it's
happening patch 1.5 made sweeping
quality of life adjustments to cyberpunk
2077 such as options to skip its
needlessly long braindance tutorial or
respect your skills the patch also added
ps5 and xbox series x and s versions of
the game as well as the ability to buy
and customize apartments and receive
saucy photos from your romance options
but that's enough talking about games
that gain features let's talk about how
elden ring lost a feature before most of
us even got our hands on it youtuber
shakiro dubai and lance mcdonald managed
to find one of the most exciting
discoveries from eldon ring's network
test build this involves an npc
character that was cut from the final
release named monk jinko this npc would
have occupied the scavenger shack near
the approach to stormville castle and
would offer to brew the player an
alcoholic beverage once forbidden to
mortals called dream brew he only asked
that the player bring him the
ingredients in order to do this the npc
gives the player a new unique item saint
trina's crystal ball which is used to
collect slumber fog from sleeping
enemies and features its own unique
harvesting animation enemies that can
have their dreams harvested can't be
woken up unless attacked and have a
small cloud of fog surrounding their
head sakiro speculates that given the
monk's location at the scavenger shack
and how collecting dream fog works the
mechanic could have been an early method
for acquiring spirit summons or it could
have been for some entirely different
questline or purpose and fun fact about
me my favorite movie is inception so i
would love to steal people's dreams in
eldon ring and i know
leo wasn't stealing dreams in the movie
but so what i'm just connecting to
things i love don't steal my dream of
this getting patched back in i want to
use it now let's talk about another cool
discovery you can attach an external
graphics card to a steam deck it's not
easy but youtuber eta prime proved that
it's most definitely possible in a 10
minute video prime walks viewers through
the steps of opening the steam deck
replacing the ssd with the gpu that's
connected via an adapter held in place
with tape and attached to an external
power supply this is definitely not the
setup you're going to want on your
commute to work or to entertain yourself
on a long flight however with this gpu
attached prime was able to get witcher 3
to run at 4k at around 108 fps on ultra
settings unfortunately though the
results aren't all as impressive as that
example and prime explained that more
recently released titles will be
bottlenecked no matter what gpu is
attached whoa whoa whoa was something
like this possible for the switch has
someone done it already i mean i guess
it wouldn't matter you can't change
graphical settings on a switch so even
with a beefier gpu mario kart 8 is still
going to look like mario kart 8.
oh well let me know in the comments when
you think the switch pro is finally
going to come out and whoever gets the
closest answer to the actual release
date has to buy me one when it drops all
right i'll see you tomorrow
you